[Music]  Shia LaBeouf has us scratching our heads  again the recent snaps show the actor on  set clad in a fat suit and a balding  mullet do next to co-star fka twigs the  32 year old is currently filming honey  boy in which he wrote the screenplay  based on his real-life upbringing  LaBeouf yeah the story is about a child  actor working to mend the relationship  with his law breaking father Shia plays  his own father Jeffrey getting candid in  a March interview with Esquire LaBeouf  said a lot of the issues he brought up  in therapy related to his father quote  that dude is my gasoline adding my dad  handed me a lot and it wasn't scarring  he handed me texture my dad blessed me  that way  [Music]  [Applause]